>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Francisco Macias:
Thank you, everyone.
Hello, and welcome.
I am Francisco Macias from
the Law Library of Congress.
We have had an amazing series
of events in observance
of Hispanic Heritage Month.
And I would like to thank all my
colleagues for their commitment
to making 2016 another huge success
in the showcasing of our heritage.
What is additionally
noteworthy for today's program is
that October is also LGBT History
Month in the United States.
So today's program is particularly
significant for two communities
that embody the American mosaic.
I would like to thank the Hispanic
Division, our natural partner,
the Library of Congress
Office of Equal Employment
and Diversity Programs, the
African and Middle Eastern Division,
the Rare Books and Special
Collections Division, LC GLOBE,
and the LC Hispanic
Cultural Society.
It would be normal for quality
to wane a bit at the end
of a month-long celebration.
But I know this isn't the case here.
In fact, I believe we are
ending on a very high note.
And it is the collegial
spirit of people
from these custodial
divisions and organizations
that has made possible this program.
Special thanks to my colleagues,
Nicholas Brown and Roberto Salazar
for their support throughout
the planning
and execution of these programs.
Both of our guests today are
extraordinary in caliber.
So I will introduce them
in alphabetical order,
Dr. Josiah Blackmore is a
Nancy Clark Smith professor
of the Language and Literature of
Portugal at Harvard University.
For 22 years, he taught at
the University of Toronto.
In addition to the history
of the sexuality in Iberia,
especially that of Portugal,
his research interests
include the literary culture
of maritime expansions,
shipwreck narratives, Luso-African
and counter narratives in the
medieval and early modern periods,
the Galician-Portuguese
lyric schools of the 13th
and 14th centuries and
modern Portuguese poetry.
He has held visiting
professorships at Harvard,
and at the University of Chicago.
And in 2006, was visiting scholar
at the Ernest Oppenheimer Institute
for Portuguese Studies
at the University
of the Witwatersrand's
Johannesburg, South Africa.
And I have to pause there.
His books include "Manifest
Perdition," "Shipwreck Narrative
and the Disruption of Empire
Moorings" -- pardon me, "Moorings:
Portuguese Expansion and
the Writing of Africa."
And in addition, Fernando Pessoa's
English translations of poetry
of the first-known gay
Portuguese poet, Antonio Botto,
"The Songs of Antonio Botto."
Professor Gregory S. Hutchinson
is associate professor of Spanish
in the Department of
Classical and Modern Languages,
an affiliated faculty in the Middle
East and Islamic Studies Program
at the University of Louisville.
He has published on gender,
sexuality, and queer desire
in the Spanish Middle Ages,
attributing to edited volumes,
such as "Same Sex Desire Between
women in the Middle Ages,"
"Queer in the Middle Ages," and,
"Under the Influence Questioning
the Comparative in Medieval Iberia.
With Josiah Blackmore, he co edited
the book "We Are Here to Learn about
"Queer Iberia", Sexualities,
Cultures and Crossing
from the Middle Ages
to the Renaissance."
His current research explores the
sites of negotiation between Islam
and Christianity in
Medieval Iberian text.
Please join me in welcoming
Professors Blackmore and Hutchinson.
[ Applause ]
>> Josiah Blackmore: Thank you
very, very much, Francisco.
I know -- and thank
you all for attending.
I know Greg and I want to extend a
very sincere and heartfelt thanks
to the Library of Congress, and to
Francisco Macias for inviting us
to come, because this
has been something ever
since we received the invitation
we've been looking forward to.
And we've been exchanging e-mails,
and texts, and at the prompting
of some excellent questions
that Francisco provided us
about a month ago,
Greg and I are thinking
of just having a conversation here
about the book, how it was born,
where we think the field is going;
and we invite your participation.
So Greg is going to begin by talking
a little bit about the back story,
the scholarly and disciplinary
back story of "Queer Iberia"
when we first started thinking about
this project in the early 1990s.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Thank you, Joe.
And I echo Joe's note of thanks
for Francisco in particular.
I feel like we've become
old friends,
even though today is the
first time we're meeting.
And actually PowerPoint, if you
could bring up the first slide,
which is going to very important.
Joe and I have been talking about
this, and actually not only Joe
and I but also other colleagues
in our graduate program.
We were both graduate students
at Harvard back in the '80s.
We've been talking about
this topic probably
for a good 30 years at this point.
And last night we had yet
another animated exchange.
Every time we get together,
we end up talking about
"Queer Iberia" and its resonance.
Very animated exchange over drinks
at my hotel, leading, once again,
to new ideas and sparking new
interests between ourselves
in the topic, or what I've come to
call the ""Queer Iberia" project.
for me it all started with what
you see on the screen right now,
which is the volume
that came out in 1980.
John Boswell, I think for
everybody, is the iconic volume
for anybody who's studied
homosexuality in the Middle Ages.
"Christianity, Social Tolerance
and Homosexuality," for those of us
who were graduate students
at that point in time,
a seminal because it
really gave us a sense
that this is a legitimate
topic of research.
So much so for me that as I was
trying to come up with a topic
for my dissertation -- here I
was a [inaudible] medievalist,
working with a very renowned
member of the Harvard faculty,
Francisco Marquez Villanueva,
who was my dissertation director.
I in collaboration with
him was trying to come
up with a topic for my dissertation.
So excited about this volume was
I that I marched into his office
in [inaudible] Library and said
very boldly, "I would like to work
on homosexuality Hispano
Middle Ages."
And his reply I'll give it to
you in Spanish first and then,
the translation, his
reply was, "Pues, pues."
And I don't -- Yan [phonetic]
recognizes that accent, "Pues, pues.
[Speaks Spanish]," which
in translation means,
"It would be better not to
leave here, leave Harvard,
with a sword in the hand."
In other words, careful with
that topic, careful with working
on something that still is
so terribly controversial
in the academy.
I ended up obviously working on
a completely different topic,
it was a song book
from the 15th century.
But Joe and I kept up the
dialogue, and I guess shortly
after we both had degree in hand
and had our first professional
appointments --
well I'm going to turn
it over to Joe.
He'll talk about what happened next.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Well, I
mean, Greg is completely right
that as graduate students,
this whole conversation began,
And it was kind of -- it was like
trying to find form for some ideas.
And when the very first professional
conference that Greg and I went to,
we went to it together, which
was Kalamazoo on a conferences
on Medieval Studies, and in the
early '90s, we were noticing
that there was nothing on sexuality
studies in medieval Iberia,
participating in then current
discussions of an evolving field.
So we decided that maybe we
could put together a small panel
at Kalamazoo to think
about some of these issues.
So in 1994, we had our panel,
"Queer Iberia", and four presenters;
we had invited four presenters,
who ended up being
contributors to the volume.
At the time, this was unheard
of in Hispano medievalism
in Iberia studies.
This was a topic no
one was touching.
And the response was so vibrant
in May of 1994 at that conference
that we decided we needed
to do something with this,
something to take it beyond the
conference circuit and integrate it
into a larger scholarly
conversation.
And that's when we came up with the
idea of simply a volume of essays.
We ended up -- I remember our first
talk was at the airport in Toronto.
You had come up and you were going
back to Chicago, and we were sitting
in Terminal One, and we decided
this might be a thing to do.
And from that point on, the
volume took on a life of its own.
So we eventually -- we worked
up a proposal, we submitted it
to several presses, and we want
to give a shout-out here today
to Duke University Press and
the then assistant editor,
Richard Morrison, who --
Duke responded it was in
about a week's time, I think,
and they were so excited about this
that it was exactly what two
young scholars at the beginning
of their careers needed
to push something forward.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
But I should add
that Duke already had a
demonstrated commitment
to queer Hispanisms I guess is the
best way to put it, with two volumes
that had come out previously,
"Entiendes Queer Readings Hispanic
Writings," which came out in 1995,
followed by "Hispanisms and
Homosexualities" in 1998.
So this is one of the reasons
why we gravitated towards Duke,
because of that demonstrated
commitment to queer Hispanisms.
But not queer Hispano-medievalism.
Really, the inquiry of
both of those volumes began
with the early modern period.
Nothing had been done
in the Middle Ages.
And if anything had been
done on medieval sexualities,
it tended to move in one of two
directions, either sexuality
in the Middle Ages was limited
exclusively to heterosexuality,
it was the study of heterosexuality,
or if there was any treatment
of queer sexualities,
it was through a kind
of sensationalistic framework,
taking sodomy, for example,
and sensationalizing it, rather than
naturalizing it, and making it part
of a spectrum of sexualities
in medieval Iberia, so.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Yes, yes.
So one of the questions Francisco
asked us to think about is,
"Why "Queer Iberia"," in
addition to what we've just said.
And the subtitle -- to us one
of the most important words
of the subtitle is "crossings,"
because in Iberia, of course,
there are borders and frontiers
of many kinds; cultures,
sexuality, language, religion.
And these borders suggest
something very rich and faceted
that we wanted to explore
as a whole.
So between the kingdoms of
what is now modern-day Spain,
and the kingdom of Portugal,
which came to have its current
political boundaries in 1248,
we were looking to think about how
there was a certain fungability
[phonetic], or precocity, as
opposed to walls and obstacles.
So it very much was a project of
border crossings of many kinds.
And I think when we were
putting together the volume
and doing our own essays,
we certainly felt that.
And in the past 17 years, that's one
of the things I think that people
at least have said to me most of
all is how much they appreciate
that Iberian perspective
as a historical reality,
as a methodology, as a
critical methodology.
So it was something we became very
invested in, wouldn't you say?
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Absolutely.
I would also say that our queering
of medieval Iberia really --
we ended up contextualizing it
through a different kind of query,
a cultural query that had
already been a bit realized
by Americo Castro.
Americo Castro is one of the
great Hispanics [phonetic]
of the middle 20th century.
He proposed a radically
different reading of the medieval
and early modern context in
Iberia, one which took him
to far greater consideration
the 800th year presence
of Islam in Iberia.
And you can see on the map that's
on the screen right now the
furthest most northern region --
or border between Christian
Europe and what was
at that time Muslim Europe.
The Muslim presence in Iberia
began in 711 with a crossing
of Arabic peoples along with Berber
peoples into the space of Iberia,
moved to the -- virtually
to the border with France,
and progressively over the course
of several centuries the Christian
north began pushing southward.
But that border -- as Joe implied,
that border was always a porous
border, one not simply of conflict,
but also of cultural negotiation.
Medieval -- if you switch to the
next side that will give us a sense
of medieval Castro's
notion of medieval Iberia.
This probably summarizes it best.
It's from his Espania
in Historia Spain
and its history that
came out in 1948.
He says that the most
universal aspect
of Hispanic character
traced their roots
to lifestyles forged
during 900 years
of Christian Islamic
Jewish intermingling.
This brought rise -- this, as we
call it, the "cultural queering
of Iberia," the destabilizing
of Iberia as centered in Europe,
this brought rise to
immediate response in the part
of more nationalist
leading scholars,
such as Claudio Sanchez-Albornoz,
who re-described Iberia
in the context of Europe and
moreover, portrayed Iberian Spain
in particular as the
shield of Christian Europe
against the Islamic intrusion.
And eventually, that
re-conquest that what was termed,
the "Christian re-conquest
of Spain,"
it eventually had its culmination
in 1492, red-letter year,
we just celebrated it
I guess the other day,
the discovery of the New
World, but also for Spain,
a red-letter year in other respects.
The conquest by the Catholic
monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabelle
of the last foothold of Islamic
Iberia in the Iberian Peninsula,
which was Granada, the Kingdom of
Granada, the expulsion of the Jews
from Spain, and this
confluence of events
for many contemporary scholars of
a nationalist leading represents
that moment when Spain
recovered its original identity.
It finally expelled that Semitic
presence from the space of Iberia
and reasserted its Spanish identity.
For us that was the model for our
own queering, our own destabilizing
of Iberian sexualities
in the Middle Ages.
And what gave this further weight
is a comment that came in one
of Claudio Sanchez-Albornoz's
later works in 1983.
Speaking about the re-conquest, one
of the consequences, the re-conquest
for him was that homosexuality,
as he put it,
which was so widely
practiced in Moorish Spain,
would have triumphed had
the Christians not managed
to expel the Muslims from Spain.
So Sanchez-Albornoz was
also setting up that border
between Christian Spain
and Muslim Spain,
as a border between
heterosexual Spain,
represented by Christian
Spain, and homosexual Spain,
represented by alandanos
[phonetic], or the Islamic presence.
These were all provocations
for us, and gave further weight
to the project that
we were engaging in.
And I would say I've
been very critical of the
"Queer Iberia" project since then,
and probably far more
critical than Joe.
Joe has become one of the great
cheerleaders of this project.
I had ended up criticizing
parts of it.
One of the parts -- one of
the defects I see in the
"Queer Iberia" volume as it came out
is that while some of us do engage
with the cultural aspects
of medieval Iberia,
it doesn't really come to the
fore that kind of intersection
of sexual non-normativities
with the othering
of the Semitic presence in Iberia.
And one of our challenges I think
as we move forward with this
"Queer Iberia" project is
to pull into the project
that constant cultural negotiation
that's taking place throughout the
medieval Iberian context.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
Yes, definitely so.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Joe, I'm sorry.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
No, I agree completely.
One of the questions Francisco
asked both Greg and me is to think
about specific contributions,
if we had favored contributions.
And it's -- we both agree that we
cannot single out one contribution,
for a lot of good reasons.
When I think back on this
project, among other things,
it was just like an amazing
scholarly collaborative party.
The collaborative aspect on
this is what we treasured then
and treasure now.
One, we like so much the fact
that we were able to get scholars
of different critical,
and methodological,
and disciplinary stripes into
the volume, literary scholars,
cultural historians, historians,
scholars of religion
and spirituality.
So that collaborative
aspect is so strong,
and it's one of the things
we're simply most proud of.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Yes, absolutely.
>> Josiah Blackmore: When we look
back on that, and what a group
of people working together even
though with different ideas.
I remember once we
were thinking about --
and I just now remembered
this, we were trying to decide
when we were going to do
the collection of essays,
should we publish this, say, as
a special issue of a journal,
or should we try to
publish it as a book?
And one of my colleagues said,
"Articles are good;
books are better.
Nothing like a book
to make a statement."
And so we thought, "Well, we're
going to gun for the book then."
So when -- and I think the
collaborative multidisciplinary,
multi-methodological approach
that the volume represents shows
the agility of Iberian studies
as a field to engage in different
kinds of persuasive scholarship
to push at borders, to cause
crossings, to find paths.
So I think we're -- I would
say I don't think either one
of us could have done this alone.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
No; absolutely not.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
And that's one of the --
what came to my mind the most
and has been with me since 1994
when we did that session
at Kalamazoo.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: And I
would say as well that the energy
that came out of our dialogue,
starting with that conversation
in the airport in Toronto.
Joe has an incredible
memory for these details.
I'm always struck when
we chat because he brings
up things I've completely forgotten.
But the energy that came out of
that dialogue is really
what gave us the --
how can I put it, the
cajones, I guess, to --
[laughter] as very junior scholars,
to move forward with this project.
And in fact we --
>> Josiah Blackmore: And in
fact, you know, here we were,
I was two years into a
non-tenure track position.
I didn't even know if my position
was going to become tenured track.
Greg was in a tenure track position,
but seriously, pre-tenure scholars.
And I mentioned this project
to a senior colleague,
and the answer was very preemptory,
"Joe, if you do a book with 'queer'
in the title, that would
be professional suicide."
And I thought, "Wow,
what do I do now?"
Right? I listened to my
seniors in the field as guides.
But we were so -- here again, this
collaborative aspect between Greg
and me, and between us
and our collaborators,
really gave us the oomph to say,
"Well, but we believe in this."
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Among senior
colleagues as well, senior scholars
in the field; and I think that was
what ended up being most important
to us, and gave us the wherewithal
to move forward is the fact
that so many senior colleagues
in the field, whether in history,
or in literary studies stepped
up to be part of this volume.
They recognized in this volume
something that would be --
>> Josiah Blackmore:
Yes, that's right.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Groundbreaking.
And --
>> Josiah Blackmore: Yes.
So the reception -- this is a
way of us leading into the idea
of the reception of the
volume, which Greg is going
to say some things which are
really quite interesting,
because the reception in North
America, and the reception in Spain,
and the reception in Portugal,
those are very interesting
parts of the story.
Greg's going to talk about some
of the more contentious reviews
by North American scholars
in Spain and Portugal,
going to mention a
few of these as well.
As the volume made its way into
libraries and onto people's desks
to read both in North
America and Iberia itself,
every once in a while, we would get
contacts, scholars, young scholars
in Portugal and Spain,
writing us saying, "Wow,
we never thought we would
see something like this."
Because at the time, it was not
possible for someone in Iberia
to take on something called
""Queer Iberia"," right?
And I remember getting e-mails from
high school teachers in Portugal
and Spain, saying, "This
is something that finally,
this is coming out in a major press,
but it still would be very hard
for us -- " meaning
Portuguese or Spanish nationals,
to do this because it was
so risky in an academy
that was still very
traditional, very traditional.
But Greg's going to talk
about some of the reviews,
which are really interesting,
I think.
And these reviews -- in fact,
our conversation last night,
we spent most of the time
talking about these reviews
and what they mean to us
now almost 20 years later.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Well, and
I'll add to what Joe just mentioned
about the reception here in
the States, especially from --
or in Spain and Portugal
from high school teacher.
Here in the States, I'm
still struck by the fact
that when I attend conferences,
graduate students, new colleagues
in formation, when they meet me
and they hear my name,
are kind of star struck.
I'm amazed by that.
And then I realize that
"Queer Iberia" is now part
of the reading list for
many graduate programs
in Hispanic Studies.
And I'm delighted to see
that there is still interest,
and that there's still a possibility
these younger scholars moving
forward the "Queer Iberia" project.
That's something that Joe and
I are completely invested in.
But I think among the most critical
-- among our American colleagues,
the most critical were
the historians.
And Joe and I were coming
out of a program of literary
and cultural studies at
Harvard, the historians --
and we'll mention no names
because actually, they sort of --
they verge on the same
criticisms in particular.
And to my mind, in hindsight, many
of them are legitimate criticisms,
and yet I think they can all
be contested to some extent,
and serve as new impetus
as we move forward.
One of the criticisms was this
notion of Iberian exceptionalism,
that we were portraying
"Queer Iberia" as exceptional
within the context
of medieval Europe.
And this is predicated on the notion
that's brought up my Americo Castro.
We saw that previously, Americo
Castro is also talking about Spain
as being essentially different from
Europe because of that intermingling
of Christians, Muslims, and Jews.
As our historian friends -- want to
say -- one of them actually said,
"Well, Americo Castro went out --
nobody over the age of 60 is still
talking about Americo Castro."
Another one said, "Oh, here we
go again, Spain is different."
And yet, and yet, Spain and
Portugal, Iberia in the Middle Ages,
is to my mind different
in many respects.
And sexuality is being
negotiated and mediated
through a different
cultural context.
It does, to my mind,
make a difference,
and is something we do
need to tease out more
and more as we move forward.
What's interesting as well, Joe and
I talked about this, Americo Castro
in the 21st Century, that review
came out back in the 1990s.
Here in the 21st century, in 2016,
we are still talking
about Americo Castro.
He is still coming to the fore
in scholarship, and being --
if only to be contested, but he's
still a point of contention enough
so that we're being
energized by that discussion,
whether we're talking about
sexualities, or cultures,
or crossings in the
Iberian Middle Ages.
I should mention Americo -- we're
both probably, I like to say,
"intellectual grandchildren"
of Americo Castro.
He was the teacher of our teachers.
And so we are, in some respects,
very close to Americo Castro,
and he still is essential to the
way we read the Iberian Middle Ages.
I don't know if you want to
add anything to this notion
of Iberian exceptionalism.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Well, I
think it would be just the say
that when we think about
the kingdoms of Spain
and Portugal we do have
different histories there.
And it is the case
-- Southern Portugal,
you had the Muslim-Jewish-Christian
mix, but certainly not
to the extent, at least,
that you did
in the Al-Andalus, but it was there.
So you have in Portugal a
very interesting situation
where oftentimes -- and
this is something I'll get
to in just a few minutes,
documentary evidence
or archival sources for medieval
Portuguese, forms of queerness
in all of the ways we tried
to define that in the volume,
are somewhat harder to come by.
And I'll get back to that in a bit.
But I think you wanted
to talk about some
of the reviews themselves, right?
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Well,
actually I wanted to --
that was one of the next points,
one of the issues raised is
that the volume wasn't fully
representative of Iberia,
but rather focused principally
on the kingdom of Castile
and what would become
of the Spanish state.
And Joe obviously as a scholar
in Portuguese, has a few things
to say about that as well.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Yes.
Well, again, the documentary
evidence for the kinds
of queerness we're studying in
this volume tends to be scarce,
up until the late --
or up until the mid --
beginning of the 17th century.
Right; so you have a much more --
and then with the Inquisition
you have --
and the records of the
Portuguese Inquisition,
you have a treasure trove
of documentary evidence.
But nonetheless, my own piece,
which was on the medieval
Galician-Portuguese lyric,
to me is one of the most vibrant
expressions of these crossings
and borders that other
scholars talked
about in different ways
having to do with Castile
or other kingdoms of Spain.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Yes.
>> Josiah Blackmore: So.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: I think
probably one of the best comments
that came out of historical
review was one that makes the case
for contextualizing queerness in
the local and in the particular.
And as we move forward
with this project
that makes more and
more sense to me.
Yes; I do admit we cultural
scholars and literary scholars tend
to speak in broad strokes.
And the historian does keep
us true to the task of trying
to determine what is going on.
And whatever is going
on in terms of sexuality
in the Middle Ages does need to be
negotiated, not in broad strokes,
but within the particular as well.
So it keeps us honest.
And I delight in that kind of
dialogue we've been establishing
between historians and
cultural scholars as well.
But as one of our colleagues
mentions,
we tend to compartmentalize literary
studies, and cultural studies,
and historical studies in
different compartments.
Whereas in the Middle Ages,
there was really no distinction
between history, and
literature, and culture.
And from our contemporary
perspective,
by imposing those
compartmentalizations onto areas
of research and areas of knowledge,
we in some respects are not
being true to the Middle Ages.
So the challenges move in
several different directions,
and all of it continues
to be negotiated,
and I think in very powerful ways.
The Spanish reviews, I think --
>> Josiah Blackmore:
Yes, yes, go ahead.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: And that's
what you want me to get to.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
That's what I want.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
The most interesting.
We didn't realize that we would end
up in the popular press in Spain.
I think that's the next slide.
"Sero [phonetic] Magazine," which is
a gay rag, I guess is the best way
to put it, it's along the lines
of "The Advocate" back
in the '80s and '90s.
I guess "The Advocate" was being
published through that time period,
and up to the present as well.
"Sero" the Spanish response
to a magazine along the
lines of "The Advocate."
And we ended up actually --
"Sero" gave us a very brief review
in "The Advocate," if you push
the button, this will come up,
which I thought was illuminating.
We had made the assumption
-- as we edited this volume,
we had made the assumption that we
were speaking for Iberia as well.
And the review in "Queer"
-- you have to go forward.
The review here in "Sero Magazine"
talks about [speaks Spanish] --
I'm trying to get the word,
the exact word there,
[speaks Spanish] --
[ Speaking in Spanish ]
>> [Speaks Spanish].
Thank you very much, [speaks
Spanish], monolithism, there we go,
in our use of queer theory.
In other words, it was an Anglo
-- as the review here puts it,
"an Anglo-Saxon import," which
for us would be Anglo-American,
the Anglo-American
School of Queer Theory.
Here we were, colonizing the
Iberian past, speaking in the name
of Spanish and Portuguese scholars.
My argument would be that really the
queerest part about "Queer Iberia,"
in terms of queer theory, the
queerest part was the title.
And that really in individual pieces
in "Queer Iberia," there were a few
of us who were actually
engaging in query theory,
[speaks Spanish], as
we put it in Spanish.
And so I think the challenge of this
review, though, is a pertinent one
for us, and that is to get
greater collaboration on the part
of Portuguese and Spanish scholars
in this long-term "Queer
Iberia" project.
Move forward?
Probably one of the most amazing
experiences that came out of the
"Queer Iberian" project was our
collaboration with Juan Goytisolo.
Juan Goytisolo is, in essence,
has been for a long time the kind
of the gadfly of Spain's
national Catholicism,
the Nacional Catholicismo that came
out of Franckewitz [phonetic] Spain.
He had gone into exile in Paris,
is currently residing in Morocco,
and from his [speaks
Spanish] in exile
from the Spanish cultural
establishment, he has written works
that at every turn compromised
that notion of essential Spanish --
Catholic Spanish identity.
Juan Goytisolo jumped
onboard immediately with the
"Queer Iberia" project,
wrote his own review,
which came out in [speaks Spanish],
one of the major publications
in Spain, defending the project,
but defending it specifically
from the perspective
of Americo Castro.
Juan Goytisolo is very much in
line with the Castro project
of decentralizing Spain,
destabilizing that nationalistic
notion of Spanish identity.
The review that he wrote
calling -- which was titled --
[ Speaking in Spanish ]
against an anemic reading
of Spanish literature,
ended up being anthologized
in this volume
which I think summarizes
Juan Goytisolo's own project,
"Pajaro que Ensucia su Propio
Nido," which is in essence "The Bird
That -- " how can I
put that politely,
"The Bird That Soils its own Nest."
And he saw himself as that bird
that was soiling with every purpose
of soiling, soiling
the nest of Spain.
And so he very incorporated -- very
quickly incorporated "Queer Iberia"
into his broader project
of destabilizing essential
Spanish identity.
What's curious is that certainly,
whereas the [inaudible]
review understood our project
as an importation of Anglo-Saxon
queer theory, Juan Goytisolo
and a few other reviewers
as well understood it the way we
intended it, as something very much
in line with the Americo Castro
project of destabilizing.
He understood it specifically
from that perspective,
and sees us as allies, and sees the
full project as allies in the effort
to destabilize Spanish history.
So we were delighted
by that collaboration.
And actually, Goytisolo took
this review on the road.
He presented it at New York
University at my old home campus
at that time, the University
of Illinois in Chicago.
And the review keeps
going republished,
not only this volume,
but elsewhere as well.
So I think it's very much
in the forefront in his mind
as he moves forward with his
own destabilizing project.
What's interesting, I was
walking through the halls
of the Biblioteca Nacional in Madrid
two years ago with a colleague
in Hispano Medieval Studies.
And in the entryway, you have
the full array of winners
of the Cervantes Award,
awarded to those authors
in Spanish language literature who
have achieved the highest echelons.
And I made comment -- made
mention to my colleague, "Well,
one day we will see Juan
Goytisolo's portrait here
in the Biblioteca Nacional."
And his response was, "I doubt it.
I doubt it," the notion
being someone
like Juan Goytisolo could never
possibly win the Cervantes Award.
Lo and behold last year, [laughter]
Juan Goytisolo was awarded the
Cervantes prize, and this
is actually the portrait
that is now hanging in
the Biblioteca Nacional.
But of course, for
something like Juan Goytisolo,
he is suddenly becoming canonical,
which makes him very nervous.
[Laughter] So we'll see how this
plays out over the long term.
Anyway so --
>> Josiah Blackmore: I'm wondering
if now would be the time just
to mention how -- and I want to
make a comment on the cover image
for the book that we're
going to return
to at the very end
of our presentation.
That it was very gratifying
over the years
to see how this project
came to motivate other work.
And what I mean by that is in
2001, so this was two years
after the book was published, there
was a conference at the University
of Pennsylvania organized by
Michael Solomon, called "Return
to Queer Iberia," where scholars
who hadn't participated --
a lot of scholars who
hadn't participated came
to speak about their own work.
I never thought when Duke
University Press contacted us now
about eight years ago saying that
"Queer Iberia" is going
to a second printing.
You know, when does that ever happen
with an academic book
on Iberian studies.
And many projects since then have
been one way or another taken a cue
from our book, which we
find very gratifying.
Gary Chestaro, who was our classmate
at Harvard, published a collection
of essays several years
ago called "Queer Italia,"
and he acknowledges us, which
that was very nice of him.
A book, "A Queer in Iberia"
has come out recently,
and now a new volume
is in preparation,
"Queer in the Mediterranean."
>> Gregory Hutcheson: "Queer
in the Mediterranean," yes.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
So these have been,
to us, very gratifying moments.
And it's just an interesting
anecdote, I think,
how that cover image came about.
This is pure [inaudible].
When we were getting ready to
publish the book and the editors
of Duke said, "We'd like
to have a cover image
that really speaks to
what you're doing."
So I took that as a challenge to go
into the Thomas Fisher Rare Book
Library at the University of Toronto
and see what I could find.
And I remember I had
walked in and I was --
had a list of books
I wanted to consult.
And I noticed on the shelves
from across the table --
I was sitting in a multivolume
history of printing in Spain,
that had one volume was
dedicated to each city where --
that had a printing press or
that somehow had an imprint
on especially early modern books.
And so I just pulled
"Sevilla" off of the shelf,
and the book fell open to that.
[Laughter] And what that is, it is
a [inaudible] romance that exists
in a unique copy of the
Hispanic Society of America
in New York, Oliveros de Castilla.
And by reading the description,
it was almost too good to be true.
Number one, there were a series
of woodcuts for each letter
of the alphabet that were reproduced
in this printing catalogue.
And so there, for series Q,
you can see the Q beneath,
those two young men
represent Spain and Portugal.
And to the right, you can see
minarets off in the background,
and to the left you can
see a Christian church.
And I hope I'm not revealing
too personal information
about our wonderful editor,
Richard Morrison, [laughter] who had
that Q tattooed on
the back of his neck.
[Laughter] So but we just thought
it was so serendipitous that that --
I believe in signs
and that was a sign.
[Laughter]
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Absolutely.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
So that's the story
of the cover image
of "Queer Iberia."
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Well,
very quickly, whereto from here,
what work remains to be done.
And one thing I do want to mention
is that while research has exploded
in early modern Iberian
sexualities, both in Latin American,
and in the Peninsula, medieval
Iberian sexualities I would say
really has gone -- has moved
forth in fits and starts.
But there's a reason for
that, and that reason is 9/11.
I think after 9/11, many of us
in Hispano medieval certainly felt
a pull in a different direction.
If we intended to politicize
our queering of Iberia
through this volume, our political
sensibilities were being drawn
in a different direction,
of pointing to a period
in world history when Christianity
and Islam were negotiating,
were collaborating.
And much of my scholarship
-- as Francisco mentioned,
much of my more recent scholarship
looks at spaces of confluence
between Christianity and Islam
in the Iberian Middle Ages.
So those of us who would have
probably moved forward in the field
of sexuality ended up being
pulled in different directions.
What's interesting is that now
I'm trying to pull myself back
into the center between the
two, looking at sexualities,
the negotiation of sexualities, in
particular between Islam and Iberia.
But as I said not much
really has been done in terms
of the "Queer Iberia" project.
And Joe wants to talk a
bit about what still has
yet to be found in the archives.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Well, I think
that we'd like to say clearly
for everyone here, and to anyone who
might be watching this on YouTube,
we still need to rattle this cage,
right; that we're not at a --
I think there's a lot
of work to be done,
a lot of very exciting
work to be done.
Greg's going to give some ideas
about that in just a second.
One of the aspects that we
became convinced of early
on was essentially what we like to
call the "archaeological aspect"
of the book, that is
simply presenting evidence,
documents that people
did not know about,
or did not know about
in a certain way.
And I think there is still a
lot of archival work to be done,
both in Spain and Portugal,
digging through archives.
I love doing that, right, I
love that sense of discovery
with the text and [overlapping] --
>> Gregory Hutcheson: And I'm
sure nobody here enjoys that.
You just don't understand
in the least.
[Laughter]
>> Josiah Blackmore:
So that definitely there is
an archival aspect of this
that I would want to encourage, both
established and younger scholars
to approach with appetite and verve.
Because I think that there's still
a lot of discovery to be done.
Greg's going to talk a little
bit about work to be done
on the Spanish side of things, and
then I'll go back to the Portuguese.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Well,
and if you go I think it's
two slides down the road.
Let's see, maybe past this one.
Let's take a look at [speaks
Spanish] very quickly.
One of the things that -- as
Joe mentioned, one of the things
that we intended to do through the
"Queer Iberia" volume is give voice
to queer subjects in
the Iberian past.
And certainly through
Joe's work on the --
I'm not sure we can translate
this on YouTube, so we'll leave it
in the Portuguese, the
[speaks foreign language].
>> Josiah Blackmore: Okay; yes.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: His work
on the Galician Portuguese
[speaks Spanish] brings forth these
fascinating, fascinating queer
subjectivities, moving forward
into the historical documentation
of interesting friendship,
reliances between kings
and their favorites,
and into the early modern period
with what you see now being
the so-called monja alferez,
or the non-lieutenant.
This is -- and I'm going
to call him [inaudible],
and I'm going to use the masculine,
because I think it's important
to return to this story.
Mary Elizabeth Perry, the
historian, brilliant historian,
worked on this figure in particular;
and her chapter is
included in "Queer Iberia."
She tells about the non-lieutenant.
She opts to switch back and forth
between the masculine pronoun
and the feminine, this
in recognition
of Irouso's [phonetic] constant
crossing of gender boundaries.
Irouso was born in Northern Spain,
was sent to the convent
very quickly.
At the age of 14, she escaped from
the convent, dressed as a man,
assumed the name "Francisco Loyola,"
and lived his life from that point
on as a man, moving to the New
World, getting into bar brawls,
getting very close
to marrying as well.
Coming back to Spain, after
having been discovered
as not really being a -- having
the masculine gender at birth,
that's a good way to put it, he
was brought before the Inquisition.
And it was finally determined by
the pope himself, finally determined
that he could indeed live his life
as a man; and he died as a man.
What I think is most
interesting about the text --
and I've given it to
you in the Spanish,
is in the narrative it's
told by Irouso himself.
You can see, if you
can read closely --
and I've left it in the
Spanish because we lose it
in the translation into the English,
she begins the text,
"[Speaks Spanish].
I was born Dona Catalina de Irouso."
A little further on,
"Y yo muchahca."
She had an encounter
with another nun
who would abuse her in the convent.
"Y yo muchacha," and
"I, a young girl."
But there's a point in the
text when Irouso assumes,
embraces a masculine identity.
And what's curious is that the
pronoun changes at that point.
And he says, "[Speaks Spanish].
When I entered [inaudible],"
using the masculine, "entrado."
Further on, "[Speaks Spanish].
I named myself, I embraced
this gender."
And who are we to determine
the gender of Irouso?
Who are we even to impose the
moniker, [speaks Spanish],
which keeps his gender
indeterminate.
No, no; Irouso made
the determination.
Irouso embraced gender.
Irouso lived the gender.
And to my mind, we need to return to
these stories, multiple stories --
if you read the inquisitorial
documentation, multiple stories
about subjects from the
past making determinations
about their own sexual
and/or gender identity.
We need to return to
this documentation
and really bring contemporary
trans-theory to bear
on these subjects from the past.
So that's certainly
one of the directions
that a newly-invigorated
queer Iberia project,
one of the areas we need to explore
with greater verb,
as Joe has put it.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Yes, yes.
And we think also, at least as we
get to the end of the Middle Ages
and the transition into
the early modern period,
the trans-Atlantic enterprise,
which offers some very
interesting possibilities, I think,
on the Portuguese side of things
-- I'm thinking of a fairly old
but still definitional book Richard
Trexler's, "Sex of Conquest."
I'm think of [speaks French],
or "Perverts in Paradise,"
as it was translated into
English and published.
The work of my late Toronto
colleague, David Higgs,
who was doing work on early
modern male homosexuality
in Portugal and in Brazil.
So these areas with -- I would
probably say with the exception
of Irouso and Barbara's essay,
that trans-Atlantic queerness
is something that we just kind
of hinted at and touched
upon in the volume.
And I think there's a
lot to be done with that.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: And
the burning question for many
of our colleagues in studies of
sexuality, where is the lesbian?
Many feminists have talked about
the lack of documentation of lesbian
or same-sex sexualities between
women in the medieval past.
Well, a lack of documentation can be
explained very readily by the fact
that what was being
legislated against was sodomy.
And sodomy was principally
a sin committed between --
or it was exclusively a sin
committed between two men.
If you move onto the
next slide very quickly.
I wanted to give you
some manuscripts as well,
which of course makes Joe and Lee
very excited to look at manuscripts,
to feel manuscripts, and also
to see these manuscripts
now being digitalized
so that we have ready
access to them.
This is the law code of [speaks
Spanish], which was pulled together
by Alfonso X in the 13th
century, or complied by order
of Alfonso X. This
is the iconic title
which condemns the vice
or the sin of sodomy.
And what's interesting is that the
formulation is strictly in terms
of male-male sexuality,
"[speaks Spanish].
Sodomy is the sin in which men
lie with other men," no mention
of women whatsoever until
the 16th century in addition
of the [speaks Spanish]
by Gregorio Lopez.
Gregorio Lopez includes
the original text
with the Latin gloss
surrounding the text.
And we can see -- next slide; we can
see that the he makes an addition.
He says in the note you can see at
the top, he says, "[Speaks Spanish],
and also with women who happen
to commit the same
sin with other women."
What's interesting here, though,
is that it's still conceived
of as an active sin,
as an active act.
In other words, the one who was
sinful in this act is the woman
who penetrates the other woman.
So it's still understood in
terms of an active sodomy,
of a woman's appropriation
of the male prerogative.
So there's so much more to
be teased out of these texts,
so much more that we need to do.
Not only in terms of our archaeology
of queer subjectivities in the past,
but those mechanisms of control
by which these sexualities
are being configured,
or through which these
sexualities are being configured.
I would love to see
scholars look more diligently
at the archival record for same-sex
desire between women in the past.
Because if it's not being -- if
it's not cropping up in [inaudible],
if it's not being legislated
against, that does mean
to some respect that it's
happening legitimately,
that it's listened [phonetic],
that that there's an area
that's not being legislated
within which these same-sex desire
between women could
be actively pursued.
And we need to find ways of
documenting same-sex desire
between women in the
pre-modern period.
>> Josiah Blackmore: I wonder
if now will be a good
time to go to our final --
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Yes,
absolutely; very final one.
Go past that one.
One more. There we go.
>> Josiah Blackmore: So Greg?
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Ah,
returning to the cover image.
David Halperin came out a few years
ago with a book by the name of "How
to Do the History of Male
Homosexuality," and he renders
in far more complex terms
the notion of friendship
and male-male sexuality in the past.
The question we pose to
ourselves as we look at this --
as we read Halperin's
scholarship and take a look
at this woodcut is what sexuality is
being represented by this woodcut,
or what genders are being
represented by this woodcut,
what subjectivities are being
represented by this woodcut?
So this cover image, which actually
is not even mentioned in any
of the essays in the volume,
and in fact, we were remiss
in not including it -- we
simply have an acknowledgment
of the Hispanic Society of
America, but we completely forget
to identify the source of this
woodcut in the volume itself.
However, it does incite
us to go back
and reexamine not only this woodcut,
but the broad genre of
romances of chivalry.
And the visual representations
of friendship,
or male-male relationships, or
female-female relationships,
whether visual and textual.
And what I love is the fact that
one of our reviewers makes note
as well as the cover image.
And I will go ahead and
translate very quickly
from the Spanish the two Oliveros de
Castilla on the cover end up being
in the final analysis much more
than a mere decoration or a dormant.
Without a doubt, more efforts,
such as the "Queer Iberia" body,
more efforts are needed so that we
end up understanding among ourselves
or all of us, we end
up understanding what actually
is happening in that glance
between the two of them,
and in the holding of hands.
So here's one of our colleagues
in Spain in Iberia itself looking
at that image and projecting
forward areas --
potential new areas of research,
and potential new collaborations
between Iberia and the
Anglo-Saxon school,
or the Anglo-American school.
Fruitful areas of research that
will begin exploring the broad range
of queer subjectivities, also an
effort -- and I want to say this,
this is important as
well, an effort not
to sensationalize these
queer subjectivities,
but rather to pull them out of
-- as one of colleagues has said,
"Out of their closets of wonder,
and to naturalize them as part
of the broad range of sexual
and gender identities
in the Iberian past."
So --
>> Josiah Blackmore: Good.
Francisco, I wonder if we
could take a few questions.
>> Francisco Macias: Sure.
We may have time for just one or
two questions before we wrap up.
And then we want to
invite you to stick
around for a book signing
afterwards.
Yes, sir.
>> Oh, George [inaudible] from
the College of William and Mary.
I'd like to thank you for
starting with John Roswell,
an alumnus of our college.
And tomorrow we start our homecoming
weekend, and as always we start
with the John Roswell
Memorial lecture.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
And your college is?
>> George: The College of William
and Mary, Williamsburg, Virginia.
Also want to agree with Joe
that [inaudible] [laughter].
The [inaudible] was very happy
to republish the results
of that conference.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Yes; absolutely.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
That was excellent.
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Absolutely.
>> Josiah Blackmore:
That was very good.
Thank you.
>> And it's still the first of
our list of online resources.
It's available online at [inaudible]
website, and we're grateful
to continue to offer that --
>> Josiah Blackmore: Thanks, George.
>> Dialogue.
The 15th anniversary of
publication of that "Return
to Queer Iberia" series,
and we're really grateful --
>> Gregory Hutcheson: Right.
Oh, boy.
>> To have that on our website
as one of the authors --
>> Josiah Blackmore: Well,
here is a -- thank you, George.
Here is a perfect example
of what I am talking
about scholarly collaboration.
[Speaks Spanish], which is
an award-winning journal
of Hispano medievalism under
George Greeney [phonetic]
as editorship has been
more than accommodating.
And that kind of scholarly
collaboration is really priceless.
So thank you, George.
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
And I should say as well
that [speaks Spanish] was a very
willing potential first site
for the publication of
the original volume.
We -- George was more than
ready and more than willing
to publish [overlapping] --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
But we came back; we came back.
>> We lost to Duke.
It's okay [inaudible]
"Queer Iberia,"
so thank you for [inaudible].
>> Gregory Hutcheson:
Thank you, George.
>> Francisco Macias: And I believe
that's all the time we have today,
folks, but please stick
around for the book signing,
and to chat with them a little more.
Thank you so much.
>> Josiah Blackmore: Thank you.
Thank you, Francisco.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov